why is everyone so convinced that drinking alcohol equates so good time?
in fact it's honestly the biggest waste of time for you
don't you wanna live your life being productive?
being present for your friends and family,
spending time doing the things that you actually enjoy,
not wasting it on alcohol?
Not only that it's not healthy for you
alcohol is literally poison
your body knows that and that's why people get sick
hangovers are just not worth it
it may be fun for a short time
but it's not worth it
your body will thrive when it's not metabolising alcohol
yeah some people can use excuse, “oh it's to relieve some stress”
Is it??
In fact, I think it's a temporary band aid
Having one drink isn't gonna make all your problems go away
there's so many better ways to relieve your stress
go on a walk, go outdoors,
meditate, pet your dogs,
hang out with your family, self care
there's just so much more you can do to relieve stress
and I promise you you won't find it at the end of a bottle
Today's society
has been absolutely brainwashed to think that alcohol is good for you,
When it makes everyone a lesser version of themselves.
Yeah you can make fun of the person who doesn't drink,
call them a party pooper
but really, who's actually thriving in life?
Probably not the person drinking